'españa de un giro histórico en la
defensa de los derechos de las mujeres
la semana pasada el congreso de los
diputados aprobó el proyecto de solo
sigues y esto después de más de dos años
de discusiones sólo falta que el rey
felipe sexto firme esta nueva ley para
que entre en vigor la normativa
considera que toda la relación sexual
que no sea consentida por la mujer se
tratara de una agresión sexual el cambio
está en que antes en españa las mujeres
deberían mostrar que habían sido
forzadas y que habían se habían
resistido para que el delito fuera
penalizado como una violación saludamos
entonces a nuestra segunda invitada del
día ella está en 9000 lópez trujillo
periodista de neutral especializada en
feminismo salud y derechos reproductivos
también en premio de periodismo de
violencia de género 2017 9000 es un
gusto que ustedes nuevamente con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
hablemos del pilar de esta ley no que es
la diferencia penal que había entre
abuso y agresión sexual qué significa
esto en términos jurídicos en españa'
bueno hasta ahora la diferenciación
básicamente es que la agresión sexual
solo se tipificaba como tal cuando había
habido violencia o intimidación es decir
algún tipo de violencia física o que por
ejemplo pues como fue el caso que ha
dado digamos lugar a que exista esta ley
que te rodeen por ejemplo un grupo de
hombres es decir que para que fuese
agresión sexual tenía que haber habido
violencia o intimidación abuso sexual
era un acto sexual no consentido también
es decir la víctima no consentía pero no
no se había hecho uso ni de la violencia
ni de la intimidación ahora con la ley
de libertad sexual ya aprobada
básicamente esa diferenciación se
elimina es porque se equipara ya no
existe el abuso porque de alguna manera
desde el feminismo se entiende que lo
que es violencia o intimidación es muy
amplio y que el hecho de que a lo mejor
no te no te agredan físicamente
pero por ejemplo te echen algo en una
bebida también se puede interpretar como
una forma de violencia y que lo que
importa es que hay una ausencia de
consentimiento el cuando en ausencia de
consentimiento se entiende que es una
agresión
claro 9 me también recordemos el
antecedente de esta ley el aberrante
caso de la manada no en la fiesta de san
fermín haya también en españa' que
provocó en la sociedad española este
caso que precedentes en todo en esta
sociedad para el despertar también del
movimiento feminista y hacer realidad
esta ley que pues está esperando sea
firmada por rey felipe de sexto pero que
seguramente lo va a hacer para que ya se
instaure como reglamento en españa'
si es inminente que la ley entre en
vigor es como un mero trámite lo que lo
que falta será próximamente publica en
el boletín en el boletín oficial del
estado y el caso al que te remites es
pues el caso de una víctima no que
efectivamente en 2016
digamos que tuvo la valentía de
denunciar lo que le había ocurrido que
es básicamente que había conocido a unos
hombres en las fiestas de los
sanfermines en el norte de españa y
bueno pues le acompañaron en el camino a
casa y en un momento determinado la
introducen en un portal contra su
voluntad y sin que realmente utilicen lo
que hasta ahora la jurisprudencia lo que
los jueces entendían por violencia o
intimidación
básicamente pues sin su consentimiento
en la agreden sexualmente no entonces
las primeras sentencias
condenan a los agresores por abuso
sexual porque se entiende que no han
utilizado violencia ni intimidación y
sin embargo pues lo que dice el tribunal
supremo- es que no se debe entender la
violencia o intimidación solamente pues
eso no como pegarte una paliza a ponerte
una pistola en la cabeza o intentar
asfixiar te que es como en el imaginario
colectivo una manera muy patriarcal de
entender la violencia sino que a veces
la violencia es más sutil y no por ello
deja de ser violencia entonces con esta
sentencia del supremo- se sienta una
jurisprudencia muy importante que
canaliza ahora en esta ley osa digamos
que en un juicio ya no sería pues es tan
difícil digamos constatar el
consentimiento de la mujer para una
relación sexual o sea como pueden pelear
digamos las partes en un juicio para
decir que en efecto esta mujer no tuvo
su consentimiento fue obligada a hacerlo
o fue simplemente pues abusada o violada
claro o sea
en los casos penales es la víctima la
que va a seguir teniendo que digamos que
probar que no hubo consentimiento porque
si no sería una inversión de la carga de
la prueba y digamos que el que el
ordenamiento jurídico partiría de la
idea de la presunción de culpabilidad
esto no es no es viable no entonces
es verdad que la ley no solo tiene un
cambio penal sino que tiene un cambio de
paradigma en el sentido de que la idea
es dar una mejor asistencia a las
víctimas y formar mejor a los juzgadores
para que a la hora de tratar de probar
que efectivamente hubo una agresión
sexual no haya una victimización
secundaria a la víctima no se sienta tan
cuestionada y las mujeres se sientan más
seguras y más protegidas en el sistema
judicial a la hora de denunciarlo
entonces lo que también se necesita es
un cambio de paradigma un cambio de
mentalidad y un entendimiento de lo
compleja que es la violencia sexual para
que para que probar lo que fue una
agresión sexual no sólo dependa de la
víctima no y que no haya un
cuestionamiento sobre su vida sexual
anterior sobre cómo se comportó sobre sí
dijo que no suficientemente si se
resistió porque todo eso por mucho que
la ley sea muy importante si no hay un
cambio de paradigma de mentalidad en la
población española en los juzgadores en
la fiscalía
a la hora de probar que una agresión
sexual las dificultades son las
facilidades van a ser las mismas
entonces sí que es verdad que la ley
contempla formación a todo lo que son
los actores del ámbito jurídico fiscales
jueces juezas
procuradores y demás pero es importante
que el imaginario colectivo se haga
mucho trabajo de feminismo para entender
que la violación no siempre es pues que
cinco hombres te rodean te meten en un
portal y te violan contra tu voluntad
sino que a veces es más sutil es un
compañero de piso que te insiste mucho
que te hace chantaje emocional a veces
es tu propia pareja y todo eso es lo que
hay que entender para que digamos que el
cambio social acompaña a la ley porque
una ley por sí sola una regla un
problema tan complejo este cambio de
mentalidad que parece que no tienen los
del partido popular de derecha o boxes
de extrema derecha que se pusieron esta
ley porque la tildaron de aberrante
también dijeron en alguna oportunidad
que esta normativa se hizo para destruir
a los hombres porque cuáles son los
argumentos de ellos
bueno uno de los argumentos es que la
ley no protege a los hombres ellos
digamos que desde el partido desde box
no desde esa ultraderecha que tiene
representación parlamentario ahora mismo
sí que hay una idea de que no existe la
violencia contra la mujer la violencia
patriarcal no es la violencia de género
entonces desde esa negación entienden
que cualquier tipo de diseño de política
pública que sea para dar garantías y
derechos a las mujeres no yo incluso a
otras y a otras poblaciones vulneradas y
minorizadas como puede ser la población
lgtbi consideran que no tiene sentido
porque que creen que todo el mundo ahora
mismo en españa tiene igualdad de
derechos lo cual lo cual no es cierto
entonces bueno pues claro se oponen a
este tipo de leyes que intentan
garantizar
más seguridad y más protección para ante
la desigualdad de género que todavía
existe claro igual noemí además como lo
estábamos conversando se tiene que
probar que en efecto pues allá esta
violación sin el consentimiento de la
mujer y que pues ahí está todo el mayor
asunto es la dificultad
digamos que encuentra la víctima que le
crea en los juzgados o que le crea el
jurado de que realmente fue víctima de
una agresión sexual o una violación
pero efectivamente es que si sigue sin
haber suficientes pruebas o las pruebas
no son contundentes no se va a condenar
a ningún hombre esta idea de que
simplemente porque una mujer diga que ha
sido víctima de una agresión sexual
directamente se le va a condenar es no
entender cómo funciona el proceso el
ordenamiento jurídico va a seguir
habiendo una fase de instrucción donde
se tiene que ver si el testimonio de la
víctima es sólido si efectivamente pues
hay testigos no qué pruebas hay para
pues como en cualquier otro delito que
pruebas tienes para armar un relato
sólido que permita determinar que
efectivamente la vía en la víctima está
diciendo la verdad y que ahí hay un
agresor que ha cometido un delito toda
esa fase de instrucción va a seguir
siendo la misma la ley lo que trata de
procurar es primero un cambio de
paradigma en el sentido de que haya
de que haya menos prejuicios y menos
estereotipos en el ámbito judicial
porque hasta ahora se entendía pues eso
no que si la víctima no se resistía lo
suficiente o incluso por la forma de
vestir que puede llevar en un
determinado momento puede estar
digamos promoviendo no ser víctima de
una agresión sexual esos estereotipos se
aplican y es lo que se trata de
erradicar pero el lolo probatorio
digamos la fase de instrucción lo va a
seguir siendo igual lo que se va a
intentar no hacer es que los jueces
sientan que tienen la potestad para
preguntarle una víctima si cerró
suficientemente las las piernas o si va
a vestir de una determinada manera o no